yeah perfect nobody touches anything
[Laughter]
anymore all right cool um yeah uh
everybody Welcome uh in our par office
first of all I want to thank you that um
it's a big honor for me giving this talk
to you and telling you something about
um yeah my daily work and working with
time series data time series forecasting
so I'm really I'm really honored giving
you this talk today um the name of my
talk is as you see it beyond toy data
sets um time Ser forecasting uh for real
B business um for re business problems
my name is Robert I'm a physicist
studied here in heidleberg from Bachelor
and Masters um during my masters besides
working in condence metaphysics I was
deep deep diving into um forecasting um
into forecasting model sorry for I don't
touch anything um I was deep diving into
a Time series forecasting a lot um also
I was investigating and studying back in
2019 um already Transformer algorithms
and um Al implementing my own um
Transformer based algorithms brought
them into production and I think it was
at that time that when I realized that
there is great potential within those
algorithms namely being Transformer
based or being any kind of deep learning
Tech technique and that we should able
use them as well next to other other
more fundamental statistical methods or
machine learning methods um yeah back in
University I was then very very
motivated to just use my knowledge about
all this all this technology and then
just go into the industry and just apply
it um but then I brutally experienced
two things um in reality in real
business problems like Exel still seems
to be the best um best best practice and
secondly the data sets I was working
with then in Industry were not as
beautiful as they were in University
they were not like prepossessed for me
they had gaps they had they had
everything but it was not nice it was
not that beautiful so um especially that
last last Point motivated me to give
this talk to you today because I want to
emphasize basically the differences that
we that we see in reward scenarios and
also some Concepts that need to be
applied in order to cope with those
reite scenarios and with all the with
all those little um with all those
little uh traps that you can that you
can basically be being uh walk in and um
basically what I want is uh the goal of
today would be that you understand the
basic concepts the basic ideas of if you
ever find yourself in the in the
situation of coping with time serious
forecasting problems you do understand
the basic concepts and ideas of it and
you'll be able to avoid those pitfalls
and just turn your use cases into
success
story
um yes so um I think fabian's already
said g gave us a small outline about
paros itself for me working as an AI
scientist here what
I what I what I um why I see our
approach as Superior
um is because we don't stop at purely um
implementing or um deploying machine
learning models itself we don't stop at
the prediction itself we want to use the
predictions
and um and and put some optimization on
top of it in order to not
only uh do the predictions but also
enable um decision makers um decision
makers to be able to to to to to do
optimal decisions on top of our
artificial intelligence I think think
sorry for
that
um yes I think it's very important to to
to leverage decision to to help decision
makers making optimal decisions within
complex environments and this is what we
at Paro strive
for all right um let's look at our
outline first of all I want to give you
uh a brief
introduction into time series
forecasting in general um afterwards
um um doing doing station fin um
secondly uh I want to talk
about um to to go from Toy data sets to
re to re business problems I will
explain later what I mean with toy data
sets but um I think this is a very
important distinction we should make
here and third but not last um I want to
give you some ideas of how modeling in
reword scenarios um does does look like
what are the the things the pitfalls
that you have to be aware of in order to
turn use case into success stories and
also especially in the um give you some
examples in the analysis of uh what what
what we all need to what you need to
take care of as well so first of all um
probably you all know this guy uh for
our International Spectators okay this
is G ya one of the big German quiz
Masters or show Masters and he's asking
you following question and I want to
take I want you to take out your phone
or I don't know if you have pen and
paper with you and just type in what is
the first and most important step when
doing time service forecasting okay we
have answer a which would be the hyper
parameter tuning so if you want a
machine learning model you need to
optimize it we all know that so um
definitely important we have running the
baselines um meaning running some some
some some simple models as well next to
some some some other models might help
you might doesn't help you I don't know
um C would be used the latest state of
the art models we all read about
Transformer models we read about MLP
based models um multilayer perception
models um maybe also stay always being
up to date um can definitely help you
with the results or D ask what am I
actually doing
here so uh please write on your question
I will reveal um in the end what was
what's my right answer at
least okay
um all right that was good
sorry I just changed my docking
station yes now this is not
right
um display settings or
what duplicate
slideshow
sorry does anybody know where to click
here which one
yeah
uh yes
almost I see it very
good ah okay perfect perfect that is
perfect thank you
for um yeah thanks for being so patient
with my tech ises you know deep Tech is
not always that
easy all right um so um I wanted to give
you a brief overview about what time
series is about actually it's quite easy
you your basically what you have what
you're doing is you're predicting some
future observations based on your
historical values I mean time series
normally it's not that it's not that
widely spread in it's not like a
classical machine learning technique or
um as um like like an area but we see
those time serious basically in every
company because every data that is
tracked over time can basically in the
end be implemented and formulated as a
Time serious problem where we see the
most um the biggest Leverage is for
example in e-commerce um companies where
they sell like they have a big
e-commerce shop and they sell 10 20,000
sometimes 100,000 different products and
they need demand for every single
product in order to um to to make their
supply chain
um effective so knowing the time series
the demand in this case up front is a
big Advantage for the for their business
um secondly we also see for example
Finance is I mean this is um for example
stock stock forecasting all that stuff
with that is that is tried sometimes
more successful sometimes without any
success um but these are classical
classical areas of um Time s
forecasting um let's don't get
distracted too much by the by the whole
mathematical definition
all I want to show you is basically um
that we we do predict some targets why
based on some feature metrix X we can
therefore also since we predict multiple
targets at the same time we can
basically explain the times with
forecasting as a multivariate regression
problems where you just predict multiple
targets at the same time what is
important is um what kind of features do
you have um you do have for example the
kpi itself if you want to predict the
future demand you you have to take your
your historical demand into account you
can you you have or you can take
historical features into account meaning
was your stock filled at that point in
time or not there these important
information order to predict the demand
um um
accordingly also what is important is
for example future future information
future cage which are denoted by by this
um for example is there a sales day
upcoming what will be the weather
tomorrow in heidleberg or in 3 days in
Manheim these are all important
information that we need to take into
account in order to make this prediction
more
accurate um so now I brought you a
really simple example which is the air
passengers data set the air passengers
data set is just the data where the air
passengers being tracked how many
flights were taken between the years
1949 and
1961 and uh as you can uh see this is
one of the data set that is often used
for Ben benchmarking your model so you
see if you read papers in this area you
see a lot of times okay let's Benchmark
on on air passengers there's also other
other typical Benchmark sets like Boston
house prices this is what you read
everywhere in the papers so these time
series not all of them but most but but
most of the times they do have some some
some some some simple characteristics
that are that that we can fit for for
example here um we want to we want to
characterize the trend of the time Ser
we see there's a clear Trend there's a
clear upwards Trend in in this scenario
so this is like one thing that we have
that we have to fit the other part that
we have to um that we have to try to um
characterize is the seasonality so we
see just before Before Christmas the air
passengers increases therefore this is
the seasonality part the ultimate goal
basically of Time series forecasting is
to identify Trends seasonality but also
the influence of external
information um there like I said other
Benchmark sets the air passenger set the
Boston house
prices um so this is what I was working
off in Academia and this is what I refer
to as a toy data set it's only one s
single time serice not not often super
not often super complex but it has some
some some some characteristics that can
be fit by normal um time serious
approaches but what we see in Real Life
Is that real life data setes they're
just different
beasts and I mean they they sometimes
they can they they they are they can
look dangerous they can bite sometimes
um but today I want to give you an idea
of how to cope with them even though
they look like
that okay first of all um the biggest
diff one of the biggest difference is in
these real life time data sets we see
tons and tons of multiple H hetrogeneous
data sets meaning you can have arbitrary
many data data sets data points products
in a portfolio with that can exceed 100
thousands of of skus that Al that all
have to be predicted separately and when
I say there is a lot of data there is
really a lot a lot a lot of data and
then there's data
everywhere okay so really um just
imagine we have 2 million or maybe
200,000 skus times a historical part of
what two years on a daily frequency it's
like uh 200,000 time 730 days data
points this is what this is en normal
amount that you have to expect when
working with real life data sets um what
we also see is we have lot of um data
sets for example here data spikes that
are really driven um immensely by
external factors so if you look on the
left there is there there are also data
spikes but you can you can extract them
you can characterize them by the
seasonality part by by looking at
historical values here you we know for
example here there was a sales day so we
have time series peing up within one or
two days and then drastically um falling
afterwards again and this is all being
influenced by external factors so we
have to take external factors into
account and we have to find the right
models to take them into account in
order to really come up for for a proper
um demand prediction another one is the
Cod stop problem Cod stop problem means
there are products time serious demand
whatever um where we have no to only
less historical data for that um just
imagine you have a product launch here
of a product that you never sold before
before in your in your in your in your
shop in your e-commerce company
whatsoever uh but you need to have like
a like a like a um like a picture in
your mind or like a um roundabout number
of what will be the demand and just IM
just imagine you are sitting here on
this on this pink line and you know only
that you sold nothing until now what do
you do you can imagine it's hard it's
hard to get a proper um prediction for
that but there are techniques last but
not least
um we see a lot of intermittent time
series in reword scenarios intermittent
time series are time series where it
they consist out mainly out of zeros
there is no clear seasonality or um
Trend defined and the the the the data
that you see is more or less just noise
so it's hard to it's hard to to to to
fit any kind of um any kind of um um any
kind of um seasonality or something um
it's really only that and you you have
to cope with that um since we see these
time serers a lot in different different
areas I want just to have a little bit
more de Deep dive on the intermittent
time series and just to give you an idea
what can what can be done with that um
this is also typical for
ecommercesport folio out of um 200,000
products or let's say 20,000 products
and 19,500 products are being sold
almost no there only 500 products they
drive the whole revenue and then you
have a majority of products that are
actually in a similar manner to that and
that is you need we need to find ways of
coping with that um one way I want to
show you today is the cross the method
um this is one of the most classical
methods that you can use in order to
model intermittent demand um there are
further advantages but I just want to
give you an idea of what is possible and
um then we can maybe have later on a
discussion of what else would I is also
um possible in this area so for the
cross method um sorry here um I just you
know I wrot wrote down um in the bar the
the values for the time series um just
for visualization purposes and then what
the cross method does for example it
models this onetime series separately
into two time series meaning the first
time series denoted here with the Q just
holds the nonzero values whereas the
second time Ser is the a holds the
frequency of how often does do nonzero
values occure
um in the end these two these two these
two time series here are are fitted
separately within a exponential
smoothing formula so this is a really
simple formula and you you just get your
prediction by dividing um the the Q the
predicted Q value by the predicted a
value for me it's not super important
that you understand every detail of that
and there are also further Advanced meth
methods from the crosson method but just
be aware of that there are techniques if
you look at data that look like this
before there are techniques to cope with
and you should not naively just throw
anything at it because this will
probably
fail okay this is the key
message um all right so we now looked at
the data we looked at certain criteria
of the data
so yeah so let's predict I mean what can
possibly go
wrong I mean every data scientist should
last because actually everything can go
wrong if you if you do if you if you're
handling a data science project like
this but for now we looked at the data
and we now just throw models at our
problem and you know I I I introduced
myself as an AI scientist so therefore
as a good AI scientist what I do I do of
course I pick all my neural networks
that I have just throw them at my
problem and I just see what comes out of
that and what could potentially come out
I mean this is um plot that we that we
that we see that we saw sometimes that
we see sometimes you know I've on the Y
exis I have my root mean squared error
and I want to Benchmark my nits model
this it's like a super Advanced um time
series model MLP based whatsoever super
nice um the TFT model which is like a
temporal Fusion Transformer it combines
lstm Transformer Network so it's really
really hot and I have my XG boost
probably everybody knows knows that so I
mean I see here my inet model performs
the best it's the most advanced model so
I can just deploy my inet model um my
work is done for today and I give it to
the customer
right oh what's missing
here does anybody have a clue what's
what could be missing like in order to
be really sure that this is a good model
a real evaluation real evaluation yeah
we come to that in a second yeah Bas yes
right okay okay I I don't have to teach
you anything
today a baseline correct because having
those results um just like that it
doesn't it doesn't tell you anything you
could be really good you could be really
bad you could be mediocre in between
somewhere you don't know so running a um
so having for example what is a really
really good um leverage in order to
convince customers from the business
well you create is when your customer
does his own predictions and does own
forecast and you get the numbers then if
you're lucky enough and you evaluate his
own forecast it could maybe look
something like this that's the easiest
way if you can show your customer what
he do what he does and what you do with
your models you have S such a such a
margin of how you're performing better
um to this is the easiest win to
convince someone that you actually
provide business value for your for your
Solutions um if you do not have any
customer data any customer forecast
running baselines is your bread and
butter like this is something you have
to do before every machine learning run
because right now looking at this plot
here suddenly we see that our naive
baselines and it could be various
different baselines statistical
baselines whatsoever they outperform
your whole machine learning fancy stuff
and this is not even that um this is not
even that unusual that that something
happens like this um for example
especially for intermittent times you is
we see that statistical models actually
perform quite well with that and um
having those baselines in place is super
um super important in order to to set
your results into into perspective and
you just said have a proper analysis
that's that's totally true I mean we're
talking about data sets that are super
nice having this Global summary
statistics um just looking at one number
in the end it doesn't it doesn't tell
you like the whole story of the
underlying of the underlying Dynamics
looking for example again at at the data
distribution um we see that we have also
again some Paro um Paro optimal um
situation where only 20% of products can
hold up to 80 86% of the sales volume
and 40% of the products can hold up to
96% of the whole volume meaning 60% of
the products only make up 4% of your of
your sales
volume ignoring this uh ignoring this
data statistics in your in your in your
analysis is totally will will totally um
you will totally fail by that so for
example one possibly classification is
by saying I analyze my products based on
my volume or I I analyze them based on
my variance or I build some some useful
product clusters that that reveal
basically dynamics of the data set and
also help you as a data scientist but
also your customer to understand what
actually his problem is and how your
performance is and then um your
performance can look something like this
where you see for example oh wow my my
deep learning model my machine Lear
model does perform very good On A and B
categories but it does really poorly
perform on C categories and this helps
you in order to to um to yeah to improve
your your whole your whole time series
forecasting engine
basically all right um so to summ it up
um what is very important what is most
importantly um you should always be a be
aware of the of your data and your
underlying data distributions and choose
the appropriate algorithms looking at
intermittent problems or discod start
problems also I didn't talk about that
but this can be very promising you can
provide a mixture of models um combine
the predictions and um and and and give
this as a as as your final prediction we
also see some very positive results
there secondly um choose some some
appropriate clusters on your time series
data uh for your for your analysis um
which is what is very important here
analyzing your model performance only on
clusters it does not mean to only train
on those clusters like these are two
different things and we should
definitely differentiate here because
training only on certain clusters is not
a good idea you miss a lot of
information there C running baselines
before using any machine learning any
deep learning model before even thinking
about that running your baselines doing
your homework is most importantly and
with without it you're just missing
context and it's hard to convince
yourself your colleagues your customer
in the end right so um again coming back
to the initial question um who did vote
for
a nobody for
D
yes perfect and the ones voting for B
you were right okay yeah nice I mean
it's a highly subjective question you
could would maybe tell
us you should check Che we should
check um it's a highly subjective
question but this is definitely one of
the most key factors that you should do
at every um beginning of analysis of use
case yes um that was my talk um I hope
some Concepts got clear to you even
though you're not even highly uh or
you're not even working at the moment in
this field but keeping the data
distribution in mind and also like some
analysis Concepts that you should
definitely be aware of I hope it helps
you um and yeah thank you very very much
for listening and yeah looking forward
to the pizza and the chat with
you so thanks a lot Robert for the great
talk I think we have a couple of minutes
for questions at this point there are no
questions on slido so if you're uh
looking remotely and you want to ask a
question please ask your questions on
slido but you can of course also ask
your questions Loc Al here whom who does
have a
question so first of all thank you very
much for the explanation I could relate
most of the part because I think I'm
doing exactly same stuff in my job
currently and just wanted to know your
view about how important it is to
retrain or model with the errors which
you are having in actual right so for
example we made an prediction for this
month and then we saw some actual how do
you think that the error which came
between our actual and predicted values
make sense in this kind of scenarios
yeah um I think this is enough right so
uh first of all um I think it's it's
hard to give you like um this explicit
answer of how much retraining um you
should do I mean there are certain
papers that tell you okay after four
weeks after six after eight whatsoever I
think first and foremost what is
important to always track and lock your
real life um performance so to because
um um having only your test testing data
in place or your hold outset data in
place it does not give you um it does
not ensure that also your model will
perform like that also in in life so
having this in place is the most
important stuff to always be able to
analyze also retrospective your results
um in in in in in a real life scenario I
think this is the most important step
that that you should do besides that I
think we saw depending on the on the
area depending on the business that
after um six to to to six to eight weeks
we saw in some use cases some some
performance dip so if if this is like
for us somehow some rule of thump um
especially working in high high Dynamic
areas um where you should where where it
makes sense to retrain but I think you
will see it if you track it um
constantly you will you will see it for
for the each business and each data set
um yourself yeah
y do we have more questions
ah hi uh thank you for your talk uh so
just one question uh you talked about
like the state-of-the-art models uh TFT
NH and XC boost so uh when it comes to
e-commerce industry uh especially like
Fashion retail uh where the data is very
volatile most of the times and you
hardly have any historical data in many
cases so uh from your particular
experience uh can you suggest which are
the methods which really work well for
what kind of uh product categories yeah
yep good question
um so what I so what I what I would say
and what we see is I mean they are
there's lot lot to say about that so
most important most important rule or
most important fact is the the higher
your data set the bigger that your data
set gets um the more hetrogeneous your
data set is so for example we have data
sets with or sometimes I work with data
sets 10 20 30,000 groupings but I could
take a relatively small model since the
the data set was not that hetrogeneous
to other data sets so there the data
sets they they had similarity so um I
didn't need that capacity of a big model
to really be able to to model all
different uh time seres when we see
bigger data sets more hetrogeneous data
set your model just needs capacity of
being able to model intermittent but
also um take exogeneous uh variables
into account you know in order to being
able to model influences of external
data all this stuff just means the the
more complex the problem is the more
data you have the more hetrogeneous your
data set gets the more capacity you need
and we see for example that um MLP based
nits um they're working quite well um
also they very effective you know you
can iterate a bit more faster I'd say
than with with Transformer based methods
because they just need a lot of training
time and you really need to um look
after learning rates and all that stuff
um then it's is yeah so this is my my
rule of thumb there are more Advanced
Techniques sometimes also this one
Global model does not the best job you
need combinations of models um depending
on on what data you're actually trying
to predict but
yeah
yeah do we have further questions
yeah thanks for the talk I have a
question about the cost functions that
you use do you also sometimes use more
exotic cost functions with your
customers with the customers yeah maybe
someone is asking okay rmse doesn't
matter to me I want to make good
decisions yeah as you also outlined um I
want to measure for instance how do
those metal models help me to make
better decisions mhm yeah so um so
there's definitely so so first of all
what what what we see is that um the the
metrics used to evaluate with the
customer and the the loss functions that
you're talking about training our models
um they are not necessarily always the
same um having a simple metric function
for your customer to be able to explain
how good you are in like in in numbers
that are um that are also understandable
if you're not like a matician um or
something is very very important um this
has nothing to do with what we use as s
loss functions but I think you um you
were hinting you you were hinting on
another point for example um loss
functions to see um for example if over
predicting uh the demand is more costly
for their own use cases than for example
underpredicting u meaning for example
you Overstock okay you have more cost
cost in for example your for your
warehouse but under predicting is like
really is really really bad for you
since you lose a lot of sales so that
that that hurts even more than just
overpredicting and on on the
optimization part I mean Fabian is
optimization expert here but optim on
the optimization part we obviously we
use more fancy Matrix in order to
display our actual value on the demand
prediction side um I think from my
experience it's better to use more
simple metrics and to explain um the the
the the character the behavior of your
model by that and not too fancy metric I
think on optimization side it's a little
it's a little it's a little different
right if you look at a coffee bar custom
metric are really expensive because
they're always caveat um and C like if
you optimize for them always some things
that you've never thought about
before okay thank
you all right we now do have a question
on slido asked by Gus and I try to
rephrase it uh or read it do you
considered training time and model
explanation stats and ml models usually
trains way faster than neural networks
and also helps you to understand a
little more the data yes that is a
really good question so obviously um yes
of course we include uh training times
um when when when when when choosing our
models I mean just just uh just thinking
about it um training a statistical model
can take some seconds so you do not have
to think too much about for example
about um infrastructure how you store
your models in the end you can basically
it's a trade-off but you can also say
okay I train my stats models just every
time it doesn't matter um about storing
obviously um for example when when
you're using theal networks um it takes
much more infrastructure in order to
make those models work explainability is
a very good topic I mean you have some
some some really simple models that are
purely that that that that um provides
some explainability from the shelf for
example I mean we're talking about
linear linear models obviously it's easy
you talking about decision trees where
you you not really get it's not super
Expendable but you get at least some
kind of feature importance um you do not
get that from from top of the Shelf from
the new networks we working with um that
being said there are also techniques
that make your dat that that let you
explain your your model even better
talking about Chaple values or something
like that you can for example combine
the shap values with your neural
networks and then you get at least
induced some kind of expandability um
for us I think performance is highest
prior um secondly uh
explainability all right thanks a lot I
would say before we move on we give a
warm hand to
Robert